Heute im Rasenfunk? Also eigentlich wollte ich meine Version dieses Chingis machen, wo der italienische Kommentator, also der schreitet die ganze Zeit durch und ich wollte eigentlich den Jingle fertig werden lassen und dann nochmal ganz leise nochmal diesen Schrei nochmal hochziehen. Vielleicht mach ich das demnächst. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen bei YouTube und alle Zuhörenden im Podcast. Hier ist der Rasenfunk, hier ist die Ligatur, neben mir sitzt Christian Bernhard. Hallo Christian.
Ganz offensichtlich. Und ich mag sehr den Terminus ranbaggern für Transferanbahnungen. Ich habe es für euch rausgesucht, liebe Hörer, dass ihr es nicht machen müsst. Welche Sassuolo-Spiele muss man sehen? Also Lazio, 21. Jahrzehnte werden sie gewinnen. Sie werden gegen Spezia aus der Coppa Italia ausschlagen.
Nicht auszuschließen.
Und dann gewinnen sie gegen die Roma Anfang Dezember und gegen Milan am 30. Dezember.
Am Dezember, sehe ich auch, spielen sie wieder. Insan Siro gegen Milan. Das soll sich Milan schon mal warm anziehen.
30. Dezember, wenn wir alle in der Zerwestervorbereitung sind, wenn ihr euer Essen fürs Fondue schnibbelt. Oder, na gut, da schnibbelt man gar nicht so viel, fällt mir grad auf. Na ja, egal. Das kann man sich auf jeden Fall angucken. Sassu Olo, immer ein Blick wert. Beim richtigen Gegner. So, dann sind wir aber jetzt ja eigentlich schon mitten in den Awards und bei den MVPs. Alex, wen würdest du in der La Liga zum aktuellen MVP wählen?
Ja, ich habe ihn vorhin schon genannt, den Namen. Von Girona, der Flügelspieler. Savio ist mein MVP bisher. Von ihm haben nicht so viele gehört bisher. Ich persönlich auch nicht. Leider haben wir heute keinen Frankreich-Korrespondenten hier, denn der könnte vielleicht mehr von ihm erzählen. Denn er kommt von Troye. Oder kam von Troye, ist ausgeliehen. Und deswegen wollte ich übrigens auch den Namen City Football Group nicht gleich am Anfang nennen, sondern eigentlich jetzt. Denn, Findige Hörer wissen Bescheid, Troye gehört der City Football Group. Also da wurde wieder ein bisschen der Spiele geparkt bei Girona, damit der Damen zum Einsatz kommt. Und wirklich die Entdeckung der Saison bisher unter anderem. Zwei Tore, vier Assists für Girona geschossen. Ein Brasilianer, ich glaube noch sehr, sehr jung. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie alt er ist. Also wirklich diese typischen brasilianischen Flügelstürmer fast schon. Schnell, dribbelstark, geht ins 1 gegen 1. Nicht aufzuhalten.
Warum spielt er nicht in Leverkusen?
Weil City Group wahrscheinlich. Wenn er nicht bei Troye, sondern bei Sochaux spielt oder Toulouse, dann ist er jetzt vielleicht in Leverkusen. Also das ist wirklich ein Player to watch auch in La Liga. Der macht ganz viel Spaß.
Und der MVP in der Premier League für dich aktuell, Uli?
Ja, ich habe echt lange überlegt und habe überlegt, finde ich auch irgendwie eine romantische Lösung oder so. Aber ich gehe jetzt mal wirklich auf den Wortsinn MVP, Most Valuable Player und er begründet das mit dem Bruch im Spiel nach der Auswechslung von Declan Rice bei Arsenal. Und wir müssen ja auch bei Holding Six bleiben, wenn wir schon angefangen haben. Deswegen passt das nur allzu gut. Wobei ich auch nicht so ganz sicher bin, ob das dann eine Holding Six wäre. Aber den hätte man ja in München wohl auch ganz gern gehabt. Also kurzum, wirklich ernsthaft, Declan Rice nach Verpflichtung musste sich an was Neues gewöhnen. Sehr viel mehr Ballbesitz als bei West Ham. Also sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr oder überhaupt Ballbesitz. Das gab es ja nicht unter David Moyes. Dann Umbau auf eine Einzel-Sex. Und beides hat er fantastisch gemacht. Ist für mich im Moment wahrscheinlich sogar fast der beste Sechser. Ne, streichen wir fast, ist der beste Sechser der Welt, sogar vor Rudi, weil er einen noch stärkeren… Also Holding Six kann er nicht mithalten, aber vielleicht eine Bringing Six, das ist dann eine bessere. Weil der beste Balkzirkulator im Moment in der Premier League. Ich weiß nicht, der ist einfach ein guter Spieler. Und dazu kommen noch die Dribblings, die Ballcarries. Das ist ja auch wahnsinnig wichtig, durchs Pressing durch und so. Das hat er eh immer schon relativ gut gemacht. Unterdruck, wahnsinnig stark. Wenn jetzt noch folgt, dass er torgefährlicher wird, dann ist vorbei. Und deswegen ist er für Arsenal schon so, so, so wichtig. Und man hat gesehen, was passiert jetzt schon, nach sechs Spieltagen, wenn er raus muss, wie schlecht es dann Chelsea geht.
Denen auch.
Ihr wisst Bescheid.
Vielleicht warst du schon beim Anzang Hero. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das jemand von Chelsea ist.
Denn jeder Hero, der da wäre, ist...
Nee, wer ist denn ein Anzang Hero?
Ich weiß nicht. Das fällt mir so schwer. Vielleicht musst du mir da noch mal ein bisschen geben. Ich komm nicht drauf, dass ich jetzt eine für mich zufriedenstellende Antwort gebe, die auch was Vernünftiges aussagt, ohne jetzt irgendeinen Namen zu droppen.
Gibt es jemanden bei einem Team, das eigentlich schlecht spielt, aber an demjenigen liegt es nicht? Das sind ja oft so quasi klassische Daten.
Also ich hab kurz überlegt, Dominik Kerwart-Luin zu nehmen, weil Everton jetzt gewonnen hat und er endlich wieder drauf war. Mir glaube ich, es wird nie rausgearbeitet, wie wenig die mit dem Klassenerhalt zu tun hätten, wenn der gesund wäre. Ist er halt nie. Aber würde er das sein, dann würden die automatisch Platz 14 haben. Deswegen ist das immer so, ich bin nicht glücklich mit der Aussage im Gesamten. Das, glaube ich, trifft nicht den Kern des Anzang Heroes, aber das ist der, bei dem es immer wieder war. Und da schwirrt es immer so rum. Sobald der spielt, der kann es mit jedem Einzelnen, teilweise auch mit zwei Verteidigern aufnehmen, in dieser Liga. Das heißt was. Und weil er aber dauernd verletzt ist, spricht halt nie jemand über ihn.
Ja, ich finde das passt perfekt. Christian, wer ist der Anzang Hero und der Serie A aktuell?
Sehr gut, dann gehen wir nach Bergamo, schauen wir zu Atalanta und kommen auf einen alten Bekannten aus Deutschland auch, Seyad Kolasinac. Er kam im Sommer ablösefrei von Marseille, so ein bisschen unterm Radar. Er hat letztes Jahr bei Marseille aber auch schon eine wichtige Rolle gespielt. Er trägt jetzt dazu bei, dass Atalanta defensiv sehr stabil im Moment gerade ist. Er hat die letzten drei Spiele alle gewonnen, alle zu Null gewonnen, also wettbewerbsübergreifend, auch noch mit Europa League. Und Kolasinac warum? Er hat sich gleich schon super eingefunden, ist da total fester Bestandteil und ist damage –also klar seine Physis, glaube ich, kann sich viele noch erinnern, passt auch wunderbar in dieses Gasparini-System. Aber was er ihm auch mitbringt, er ist ein Linksfuß. Und in dieser Dreierkette von Atalanta hat Gasparini in den letzten Jahren eigentlich fast immer, musste er immer, Rechtsfüße dahin basteln, quasi, weil er es nicht anders lösen konnte. Und jetzt eben hast du auf dieser halblinken Position einer Dreierkette mit Kolasinac endlich mal einen Linksfuß, der logisch auch andere Möglichkeiten, bessere Möglichkeiten im Spielaufbau gibt, der eben seine Physis, seine Athletik sowieso mitbringt. Und bei Gasperini hat den auch gleich nach den ersten Spielen schon rausgehoben, hat gemeint, seine Abgeklärtheit. Also das ist ja bei Atalanta auch nicht selbstverständlich, dass du da gleich reinfindest, denn die haben ja auch einen breiten Kader. Und deswegen, ja, für mich einen, über den nicht viel auch bei Atalanta gesprochen wird, weil klar, da ist jetzt der Ketelare, wird viel gesprochen, der vorne funktioniert, der nach diesem schwierigen Jahr bei Milan das sofort bei Atalanta jetzt eben auch getroffen hat, Vorlagen geliefert hat, Coop Mainers ist schon wieder in dieser Anführerrolle drin. Aber ich habe mir jetzt extra mal Kolasinic rausgenommen. Der passt da wunderbar rein und gibt eben Atalanta als Linksfuß da hinten so eine neue Note, die ihnen glaube ich genau gefehlt hat.
Sehr, sehr schön. Und Atalanta hat ja auch die zweitbeste Abwehr, gemeinsam mit Lecce hinter Inter. Drei Gegentore Inter und Bayern.
Und sind wieder dran jetzt auch ganz vorne.
Und sind jetzt wieder dran. Drei Punkte Rückstand. Dann brauchen wir noch einen Unsung Hero aus La Liga, Alex.
Ja, ich muss sagen, bei mir sind MVP und Unsung Hero eigentlich austauschbar. Sehr nah beieinander. Also ich hätte auch Savio einfach als Unsung Hero, weil man von dem noch nicht so viel gehört hat. Und nehme jetzt einfach Take Kubo als Unsung Hero. Hätte er auch als MVP nehmen können. Von dem hört man natürlich mehr oder den kennt man mehr. Bei Real Sociedad da wirklich eine herausragende Saison bisher. Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht, ob Nils Kern in der letzten Folge ihn vielleicht genannt hat. Das hätte nämlich Sinn gemacht.
Er hat Kubo und Isco genannt in der letzten Folge.
So, habe ich fast befürchtet, aber es ist wirklich zu rechtsspielend. Eine herausragende Saison. Hat wirklich die nächsten zwei Schritte in der Entwicklung gemacht. Ist so, so wichtig für Real Sociedad als Linksfuß auf dem rechten Flügel. Ich glaube, vier Tore in sechs Spielen. Und ist da wirklich zu einer kleinen Waffe geworden für Real Sociedad. Also auch eine ganz, ganz herausragende Saison gespielt. Macht so viel Spaß, dem zuzusehen. Ein tiefer Körperschwerpunkt, dribbelstark, abschlussstark. Also ist da wirklich in der Offensive der Schlüsselspieler von Real Sociedad geworden, würde ich sogar sagen. Tolle Form und deswegen mein Anzwang-Hiro Schrägstrich-MWP.
Sehr gut. Und welchen Moment möchtest du uns noch mitgeben, der irgendwie passiert ist in den letzten Tagen Schrägstrich-Wochen?
Moment, tu ich mich ein bisschen schwer. Ich meine, jetzt am Wochenende war natürlich die berühmte, die verrückte Remontada, also der Comeback-Sieg von Barca. Sie waren 0 zu 2 hinten hoch verdient zu Hause gegen Celta Vigo. In der 75. das 0 zu 2 kassiert. Jeder dachte sich, okay, jetzt sind sie wirklich mal fällig im Sinne von, dass sie mal wieder ein Heimspiel verlieren. Verlieren sie ja sehr, sehr selten. Es war kein guter Auftritt. Und ich glaube, in der 81., 85. und 88. drehen sie dieses Spiel. Wirklich tolle Szenen. Es war so ein bisschen Real Madrid-Feeling im Olympiastadion auf dem Montjuic. Das verloren geglaubte Spiel nach schwacher Leistung wirklich noch gedreht werden, gewonnen werden. Und da war ein Spirit in der Luft, wie man ihn ganz, ganz selten sieht. Cancelo hat eben den Siegtreffer in der 88. gemacht. Also das war so aus meiner persönlichen Sicht natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein Highlight. Aber dass sie das Ding noch drehen und nicht nur unentschieden spielen, sondern wirklich nach 0-2 in den letzten 10 Minuten 3 Tore schießen, das war schon ein ganz besonderes Spiel.
Also ich habe es aufgeschrieben, aber ich habe dazu geschrieben, Underdog siegt der Woche. Anders kann ich dir das nicht durchgehen lassen. Also ich weiß, ich weiß, das war wirklich dramatisch und die Torfolge sehr nah. Aber dass Barca ein Spiel dreht, an sich haucht mich jetzt nicht so.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, es ist ja eher Real Madrid-Style-mäßig. Man kennt es ja, wo sie nicht gut im Spiel sind, zurecht hinten liegen. Du denkst dir, dieses Spiel ist jetzt vorbei. Vor allem fällt ja sogar das 0-2 sehr spät. Da sagt man ja immer, oh, der Deckel ist drauf.
Also was er sagen will, ist lass mich.
War halt mal wieder ein besonderer Moment. Deswegen möchte ich den hier erwähnen.
Das ist ja schön, wenn du wieder was fühlen kannst bei so einem 3-2, dann ist das für mich auch der Moment.
Minimal, was man wieder gefühlt.
Ja, ich spüre es jetzt auch. Einfach magisch.
Aber um vorzugreifen, weil du willst ja immer auch das Spiel to watch besprechen, da können wir direkt vorgreifen auf das Wochenende, da empfängt Girona Real Madrid. Und vielleicht wird das ja ein besonderes Spiel, denn Girona grandios drauf. Real Madrid überzeugt fußballerisch nicht. Man hat es auch gegen Union gesehen, taten sich schwer. Ich glaube, das haben mehr Leute gesehen, dieses Spiel. Und sie haben schon letztes Jahr in Girona 4 zu 3 verloren. Da weiß Christian wahrscheinlich auch Bescheid. Tati Castellanos, der 2. Lazio, hat 4 Tore geschossen. Der ist nicht mehr da, aber die sind eben so gut drauf, dass es mich nicht wundern würde, wenn sie hier einen besonderen Sieg einfahren würden und dann hast du da ein besonderes Spiel.
Ganz kurz, Castellanos hat gestern bei Lazio reingekommen und hat fast einen Fallrückzieher-Tor des Jahres ausgepackt. Ganz knapp daneben. Das ist einer, der steht wirklich immer wieder mal gerne für Spektakel.
Gut, dann haben wir jetzt noch die Premier League. Uli, hast du einen besonderen Moment, irgendwas, was passiert ist, was hier in Erinnerung geblieben ist?
Ganz billig zwei Tore, wenn es zulässig ist. Die zu nennen sind, also zum einen Bruno Fernandes vom Samstagabend in Manchester gegen Bernley in Bernley. Weil zum einen eine herzwerbende Geschichte mit Johnny Evans, der nach 2015 wieder drauf ist für United, plötzlich einen Ball spielt. Es wäre ein richtig guter Fußballer. Und Bruno Fernandes nimmt den sensationell ab. Das ist ein wunderschönes Tor in einem fürchterlichen Spiel. Und zum anderen gestern, das ist nicht ganz zulässig, vielleicht aus dem Pokal-IFL-Cup, Dominic Soboslay, der sogenannte Thunderbastard. Den Schuss sollte man gesehen haben. Wenn man nichts an Fußball geguckt hat, das sollte man gesehen haben. Es ist einfach den Drifter perfekt. Und das ist ja kein Zufall, wie wir wissen, bei Soboslay daher, da lege ich das nahe. Und der geht so ins Tor rein, das nennt man unter gewissen Fans in England Thunderbastard.
Stark. Ich habe gestern Tweets dazu gesehen, bzw. ich glaube, es war sogar bei Mastodon. Sicher bin ich mir da jetzt gerade gar nicht. Es sind so viele soziale Netzwerke inzwischen, wo genau das thematisiert wurde. Aber ich hatte immer keine Zeit, da nach dem Video zu suchen. Jetzt muss ich es vielleicht doch machen. Man kriegt immer Hausaufgaben von euch mit. Schaut euch das 2 zu 1 an. Schaut euch das Spiel hier noch an. Und dann hier den Spieler. Naja, so ist das. Man geht hier nie mit leeren Händen raus. Gibt es denn auch ein Match-to-Watch an diesem Wochenende, Uli?
Es gibt ganz viele in der Premier League. Also das offensichtlich ist Totten im Liverpool. Das sind die beiden unterhaltsamsten Mannschaften gerade in der Liga, muss man sich, glaube ich, anschauen. Und ich nenne jetzt aber ein anderes, aus eher so persönlicher Zuneigung, das sogenannte SW6-Full-App gegen Chelsea am Montagabend um 21 Uhr. Also auch, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Zeit. Also bei Chelsea läuft es ja nicht so, wie man vielleicht inzwischen weiß. Zum einen und zum anderen ist das immer –ich mag das einfach total gern, dieses Dabi zwischen den beiden unheimlichen Nähe zueinander.
Daher kommt der SW6. Ja, okay. Dann haben wir die Premier League durch. Bleibt noch die Serie A mit einem Moment und vielleicht auch Matches to Watch.
Moment, schauen wir nochmal nach Neapel. Und zwar auch zwei Szenen da. Fangen wir an, an Uli das Tor. Also Udinese hat 2-4-1 gestern verloren. Das Tor von Samadžić lege ich auch allen nochmal ans Herz. Also ein Solo, da werden ja dann in Neapel gewisse Namen genannt, die aus Südamerika kommen. Soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen. Aber was er da ausgepackt hat, durch wie viele er sich da durchspielt und wie klasse er abschließt, also Traumtor. Aber der Moment für mich war kurz davor, ich habe Quaratzkelia vorhin schon angesprochen. Quaratzkelia hat auch einen schwierigen Saisonstart gehabt, war in der Vorbereitung verletzt, war dann am Anfang des ersten Spieltags auch nicht mit dabei. Und Quaratzkelia schwang ja schon bei vielen die Frage mit oder schwingt vielleicht immer noch bei Leuten mit, ah ja, kann der das Niveau halt nochmal halten? Also war das vielleicht letztes Jahr einfach die Saison, wo er einfach drüber war. Und gestern hat der von Anfang an, also es war jetzt wieder mal ein Heimspiel für Napoli, die waren jetzt ein paar Mal auswärts, du hast dem angemerkt, der hat von Anfang an gebrannt, der ist da rein in dieses 1 gegen 1, ich sage nicht ins 1 gegen 2, er kennt es ja auch gar nicht anders, meinst du mal 1 gegen 3, holt am Anfang den Elfmeter raus, will aber sein eigenes Tor, weil er knapp 200 Tage nicht mehr getroffen hat und du hast ihm wirklich gemerkt, der brauchte das. Packt zwei Pfosten, Treffer aus und du denkst dir, oh mein Gott, das soll einfach nicht sein. Und in der Schlussphase, ich glaube 78., macht er das 3-0, also eigentlich nicht mehr spielentscheidend, aber du hast an seinem Jubel gemerkt, wie unfassbar wichtig er ist. Ja, er ist unter die Kurve, alles ist nach. Ossi Mann auch, war schon ausgewechselt auf der Bank. Total mitgejubelt, also der hat das Tor gefeiert, als wäre es ein Tor im Champions-League-Halbfinale gewesen. Ich finde, das sind halt so Momente, wo du siehst, dass auch solche Spieler, also die auf dem Top-Niveau sind, wie sehr die dann die Momente auch brauchen. Das war so ein positiver Moment auch für Napoli, um zu zeigen, hier schaut mal her, wir haben noch so viel da. Also so viel von dem, was sonst, klar, wir werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr diese Traumsaison spielen können, aber da ist immer noch so viel Qualität da und dieses Bild von diesen wirklich sich kindlich freundenden Quaratzkele, der alles rausbrüllt, da diesen Frust, der sich aufgestaut hatte, war für mich ganz klar ein Moment und für mich auch noch zum Ende nur die Einschätzung. Ich war auch Anfang der Saison schon, also ich bin weiterhin fest davon überzeugt, dass Quaratzkele das Niveau halten kann. Also auch in den schwachen Spielen vielleicht davor, weil, warum? Er kommt über seine Athletik. Das ist ein Dribbler, aber der braucht auch den Zug dahinter. Der hat ihm halt einfach noch gefehlt, weil er eben Teil der Vorbereitung verpasst hat. Aber ich glaube, das kommt jetzt so langsam wieder. Und wie gesagt, jetzt kommen Spiele gegen Real Madrid, Champions League. Also Quaratzkele, bin ich mir sicher, wird dieses Jahr wieder groß aufzocken.
Stark. Dann brauchen wir jetzt allerletztes nur noch ein Match to Watch, wenn es denn solche gibt.
Ja, gibt auch zwei. Atalanta Juve ist am Sonntag. Da ist immer was los und beide ganz vorne dran dabei. Versuchen logisch auch, an Inter dran zu bleiben. Am Samstag ist Milan gegen Lazio. Samstag, 18 Uhr. Und da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf. Milan hat jetzt unter der Woche auch viel rotiert, hat ein wichtiges Spiel, schwieriges Spiel in Kalieri auswärts gewonnen. Nach Rückstand war ja die Frage, ob sie dieses 1.5 aus dem Derby abschütteln können. Das haben sie jetzt gemacht. Und Lazio ist so ein bisschen schleppend in die Saison gestartet, hat gestern aber gewonnen. Viele erinnern sich wahrscheinlich noch in der vergangenen Woche dieser Torhüter, der da was gemacht hat gegen Atletico, was dem einen oder anderen aufgefallen ist. Also Lazio hat bisher auch weniger eingesammelt, als sie eigentlich auch schon teilweise gezeigt haben. Und deswegen, letzte Saison waren das zwei –ich glaube, Uli, wir haben das Rückspiel gemacht in San Siro, in Milan Lazio, spät in der Saison. Da haben wir gehofft, dass Lazio viel zeigt. Da kam von Lazio kaum was, das war enttäuschend. Aber das Hinspiel, Lazio gegen Milan, die haben Lazio in dem Januar, haben Milan hergespielt. Also da war eben diese Dominanz von Lazio zu sehen. Und ich bin gespannt, ob sie da wieder hinkommen. Dementsprechend auch absolutes Spitzenspiel.
Stark. Ihr drei. Auch zu dritt schaffen wir es locker, über unserer Zeit zu landen. Einfach fantastisch. Ich danke sehr Alex Truica, Uli Hebel und Christian Bernhard. Danke euch dreien, dass ihr in der Ligatur wart. Da will keiner mehr was antworten. Ihr seid eindeutig Quatsch. Weil das Outro schon läuft, offenbar habt ihr Angst, dass ich es gleich hochziehe. Dabei dauert es noch ein bisschen, denn erst sage ich noch, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen, unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club und sagt weiter, dass es diese Sendung gibt. Gerade der Ligatur-Feed, der braucht mehr Liebe und AbonnentInnen. Danke euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Bis bald, macht's gut. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!